hey guys how's it going so one of the
things that I always ask you guys is
what new games are you playing on your
iPhone today I'm gonna show you the game
that I've been playing recently and I
found out about this game at VidCon
there's this new show on Nickelodeon
called game shakers and I got to meet
the entire cast I got to hang out with
them then I found out the premise of
this show and I was like this is
freaking fantastic and I wish that there
was a show when I was younger that was
kind of cool and nerdy like this but
there wasn't
these two girls create this game and it
becomes a number-one hit in the App
Store and this and that and I was like
this is so awesome
two girls creating a game but it becomes
sort of like this overnight success the
thing with television today is a lot of
people don't just watch TV you watch TV
and you're on your phone you're always
doing more than one thing than just
focusing on the television show so one
show is have sort of that little extra
thing that's what I think is really cool
they have got the game called sky whale
which is in the show I started playing
it and I was like oh my goodness I'm
gonna show you a little playthrough and
then I want to know what your high score
is and I'm sure most of you guys will
probably be able to beat my high score
like always it's a fun little side
scroller and you're this little sky
whale and you have to like jump and
collect Donuts
so as you like the donuts you'll have
more power jumps and there's all kinds
of fun little surprises inside let's
play and let's see what happens there's
also other little treasures that you can
get with little holes what are those
things called oh my gosh it's a star
there's a dollar sand dollars Oh what
you think of like those every time we go
to the beach okay I don't know what some
of these do but I am going to try the
burger and see what happens
yes I will take that boost please let's
go home and let's hit play go
here we are mr. sky whale okay it's the
dog got you the dog about for seven
dollars I can't believe I'm trying to
remember what the heck of sand dollar
was called if the dog died on the burger
oh I'm getting all of the things I get
the monkey dude this is a good one this
is a good I'm doing quite well I don't
like I'm just living ah please give me a
doughnut
dawn dawn okay well there's a burger get
the burger get the burger get the door
give us something
[Music]
it's record has a record a have sign if
you want to peel say again oh nothing
I'm basically just free-falling that's
game let's do it again all right let's
see what else we can get hit something
so just a little editor's note here I
didn't want you guys to see my bad
scores because I played this game on my
last flight to and from Pittsburgh so I
had a lot of time to perfect the perfect
app so I want you guys to try to beat my
new high score I got so many amazing
power-ups hmm figured out maybe the best
tactic you always want to get this
snorkel because it'll basically give you
a whole nother life span if you go into
the water
I'm gonna make it space yes right now
I'm in space like I've gotten so good I
don't know any more Donuts I've unlocked
almost everything sometimes you just
have to trust but he's gonna go up in
the right direction if I get a high
score right now like I basically just
turned this camera on and was like I'm
gonna see what I can do because I don't
want you guys to be trying to be oh no I
don't have any more Donuts Thank You
surfboard if it goes now we're two water
hit this up pick this up marine give me
the doughnuts I still haven't beat my
high score yet so I gotta keep going I
think you like 2600 no no no it is okay
oh wait
3,300 so that's my best if you guys can
beat that let me know let's Skyy well I
will put all of the info in the
description of you guys gonna play it
don't forget to check out the show game
shakers on Nickelodeon I think you guys
are actually really gonna enjoy it cuz
it's super cute I'll see you later
[Music]